[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob ich gut genug bin
keine falsche bescheidenheit wurde er
zum sprichst großartig
du kannst die regeln so einfach
entspannen naja du ich weiß ihr lernt
gerade für die sprachprüfung aber kannst
du vielleicht mein kurzem eine
steuererklärung schauen ich mache das
zum ersten mal und ich hab da noch nicht
so die gelassenheit
ich kann meine klar es war sicher ja
dann helfe ich dir
[Musik]
vielen dank jetzt habe ich ein bisschen
klarheit
ich wusste nicht dass ich meine
fahrtkosten für meine ehrenamtlichen
tätigkeiten absetzen kann
manchmal geht es manchmal nicht du
solltest es aber auf jeden fall
probieren
ich wollte wieder die ganzen sachen
überhaupt schafft nicht machst du sport
ich meine wenn ich so viel zu tun habe
dann brauche ich immer deine ausgleich
nein tue ich nicht was machst du
boxen das ist anstrengend und man kann
sich super abreagieren aber ist
vielleicht nicht das richtige für dich
also ehrlich zu sein wollte ich das
schon immer mal ausprobieren
ok
[Musik]